des écologistes des associations de
malades le dénoncé depuis longtemps les
risques en france liés à tchernobyl ont
été sous-estimés confirmation dans un
rapport judiciaire qui vient d'être
remis à la juge d'instruction en charge
du dossier
un rapport accablant et mesure
radioactive de l'époque ont été occultés
un document télévisée de 87 l'attesté
déjà patrick esther vingt ans après
tchernobyl
un rapport d'experts a donc été
communiqués à la justice française sur
les effets radiologique du passage du
nuage radioactif sur l'europe en france
le sud-est et la corse n'ont pas été
épargnées non le nuage ne s'est pas
arrêté à la frontière comme l'affirmé
les autorités en charge du dossier qui
n'avait pris aucune mesure de prévention
à l'époque
à ma droite à 200 mètres à peine
strasbourg
aucune consigne de sécurité depuis
l'accident de tchernobyl
à ma gauche à 200 mètres à peine kehl en
allemagne
là les consignes de sécurité sont très
strictes le service central de
protection contre les rayonnements
ionisants le sc perry dirigée par le
professeur pellerin minimisera alors les
chiffres de la contamination
en réalisant des moyennes par
département qui gomme et les pics les
plus importants dépollution des mesures
officielles relevé dans de nombreuses
installations de surveillance de
l'environnement par exemple celle de
l'edf situé à proximité des centrales
nucléaires mais ces chiffres n'ont été
connues du public qu'en 1987
le ministre de la santé de l'époque qui
avait la tutelle du fcpr est excusé ce
déficit d'information
ce sont des techniciens ils ont
travaillé comme des bêtes comme des
bêtes pendant un mois je crois que
jamais personne ne la cbi car ils ont
sorti des milliers et des milliers de
résultats avec c'est facile de donner la
liste de tous les gens qui ont été
touchés par ces résultats
le problème c'est que ce n'est pas leur
métier de faire de la communication
médiatique
la justice doit maintenant déterminer si
ce déficit d'information n'est pas
directement responsable de graves
problèmes de santé pour des enfants qui
vivaient à l'époque dans ces zones
contaminées où aucune protection n'avait
été prise